what's driving you crazy well the
shutdown of the ramps from the
southbound I-15 to Tropicana that is
just the beginning of Tropicana
after Saturday night's Golden Knights
game at T-Mobile
Tropicana gets real with an eight-day
complete closure of both directions of
Tropicana from Dean Martin to New York
New York so what do you do with trop
closed well the easy answer would be
flamingo
Russell for East West travel
and that sounds good until you stop to
realize that thousands of other drivers
are going to be thinking the exact same
thing so
here are three suggestions for you for
your East West travel while Trump is
closed Desert Inn
Harman
or Hacienda
again this all starts Saturday night
after the Golden Knights game we'll let
it sink in for a couple days the
complete closure of Tropicana but the
even bigger closure is coming the I-15
will be closed in both directions
between Flamingo and Russell at the end
of the month buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone and join the
driving you crazy conversation where
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com